With The Flash back on TV, let's take a look
at 10 things you probably didn't know about
the Scarlet Speedster's show.
According to the show's casting director David
Rapaport, before Grant Gustin was cast as
Barry Allen on The Flash, he auditioned to
play Thea Queen's boyfriend in the first season
of Arrow!
And Andy Mientus who brings to life the villainous
Pied Piper in The Flash initially read for
the role of the Scarlet Speedster.
Oh, and by the way, Robbie Amell, who plays
Ronnie Raymond, one half of Firestorm, originally
auditioned for Oliver Queen on Arrow, though,
of course, that role went to Stephen Amell,
Robbie's cousin!
Storyboard artist Adrien van Viersen made
over 400 boards for The Flash pilot, compared
to only half that number for the Arrow pilot.
According to van Viersen, The Flash is the
biggest pilot he and director David Nutter
have ever worked on together, and bear in
mind they've made pilots for shows including
Arrow, Smallville, and Terminator: The Sarah
Connor Chronicles.
The Flash is particularly complex as the stunt
and visual effects teams have to combine the
“speed force” effects with the live action,
and the storyboards are especially useful
for this.
About one-sixth of The Flash is computer animated,
and in the pilot there were about 200 visual
effects.
Production designer Tyler Harron based the
look of the show's particle accelerator set
on the Large Hadron Collider, though the set
is obviously a lot smaller at just 40 foot
by 20 foot.
Also, the treadmill that Barry Allen runs
on at S.T.A.R.
Labs was actually built from scratch for the
show and can go up to 16 miles an hour!
In an interview at PaleyFest, Grant Gustin
said that, at some point in the future, the
S.T.A.R.
Labs treadmill will become the Cosmic Treadmill
which, in the DC comics, Barry used to travel
through time.
If you've ever wondered just what the Metahumans
locked up under S.T.A.R.
Labs ate, a deleted scene from Season One
episode 21, Grodd Lives, revealed the answer!
According to Caitlin Snow, The Weather Wizard
is a Thai food fiend, Peak-a-Boo just loves
enchiladas, and Deathbolt is a vegan.
And Dr Snow didn't say who they were but,
judging by her food trolley, there were quite
a few Big Belly Burger fans down there too!
Speaking of Big Belly Burger, the fictional
fast food chain, which appears in both The
Flash and Arrow TV shows, first appeared in
DC Comics back in June 1988 in issue 441 of
The Adventures of Superman.
The Big Belly Burger of the comic books was
founded in Coast City, is a subsidiary of
Lex Luthor's LexCorp, and was actually inspired
by the real-life Big Boy restaurant chain.
Composer Blake Neely, who scores both The
Flash and Arrow, included a special musical
Easter Egg in Tricksters, episode 17 of the
first season.
In the episode, Mark Hamill, who appeared
in the original live-action TV series of The
Flash in the early 1990s, returned as the
villainous James Jesse aka The Trickster.
So, Neely used composer Shirley Walker's Trickster
theme which she wrote and conducted for the
1990s show.
And Hamill isn't the only actor from that
early Flash show to make a comeback.
Vito D'Ambrosio, who played police officer
Anthony Bellows in the original show returned
as the same character for seasons 1 and 2
of the new show, though this time he's Mayor
of Central City.
Amanda Pays also returned as scientist Dr
Tina McGee.
And John Wesley Shipp, who plays Barry Allen's
father, actually starred as the Scarlet Speedster
in the original series.
Actor Jesse L Martin's character Detective
Joe West doesn't actually exist in the comics.
In the comics, Iris's father is either the
scientist Ira West or the alcoholic William
West.
But despite the fact Joe West was created
especially for the TV series, he almost didn't
even make it to the second episode as the
creators were considering killing him off
in the pilot!
And if you've ever wondered why Joe is often
seen wearing a black beanie, it was Jesse
L. Martin's idea, partly to give Joe a bit
of a different look to NYPD Detective Ed Green,
who Martin played on TV's Law & Order for
nearly a decade.
If you've seen the musical Rent though, the
beanie may remind you of Martin's character
in that.
Grodd's cage very nearly didn't make it into
the show's pilot due to the cost of building
it.
Later when Grodd himself appeared on screen,
unlike Peter Jackson's King Kong or the recent
Planet Of The Apes movies, the show did not
use performance capture to bring its sizeable
simian star to life.
Instead, visual effects supervisor Armen Kevorkian
and his crew at Encore VFX built Grodd from
scratch on the computer, creating his skeleton,
then adding muscles, and then skin and fur.
The show's exec producers first gave Kevorkian
the heads-up, soon after finishing the pilot,
that Grodd was going to feature in season
one.
For inspiration on Grodd's design, the visual
effects crew looked at the comic books for
his size and attitude, and at videos of real
gorillas too.
Kevorkian also roughly acted out Grodd's moves
and facial expressions for the animators,
who sometimes also recorded themselves to
check what did and didn't work.
The presence on set of a stunt actor in a
large Grodd suit and stilts provided further
inspiration for the gorilla's actions and
also helped the crew frame each shot.
Just as the Flash's speed has increased over
the course of the series, the rate at which
the show is shot has also sped up.
For example, in the early days, they'd need
20 to 30 takes to film a straightforward shot
of the Flash running.
But now, they often get what they need in
just a couple of takes.
When Grant Gustin first started putting on
his Flash costume, it took him a whole 40
minutes to suit up, mainly because his mask
had to be glued to his face.
However, after episode eight of season one,
Gustin got a new mask that looks the same
but slides on with a zipper, which means it
now only takes him a speedy 10 to 15 minutes
to slip into his superhero suit.
The original costume, which is mostly made
of leather with some added stretchy material
for ease of movement, was designed by Colleen
Atwood.
Maya Mani, who designed Arrow's season 4 suit,
is behind the changes to The Flash's season
2 costume, which harks back to the comic books
with its emblem featuring a lightning bolt
on a white rather than red background.
Now, let me know in the comments below, who
are your favourite characters on The Flash?
And what other characters from the comics
would you like to see on the show?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know, as well as
movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, TV lovers!